today's new member of the day is
Priscilla berumen Priscilla thank you so
much for being a david pakman show
member you can sign up and join
priscilla at david pakman.com slash
membership i think lewis we should take
a few calls 617 830 for 750 is the
number you never know who we're going to
talk to we do have our first caller uh
who's on introduce yourself hi this is
Matt Matt where you come from I'm
calling from a Leesburg Virginia great
to hear from you what what can we do for
you today uh yes so uh my step dad sent
me something uh post for michael moore
on medium and he was saying that he
thinks that Trump is like was never
serious and like didn't even think he
was going to be the nominee yeah and
just wanted to get like press you know
yeah I read the article in that the
argument is that this is the way that
Trump is going to be able to go back and
get even more money in his next
negotiation with the apprentice that
that was sort of like the gist of what
Michael Moore was saying right right
yeah pretty much yeah I mean you know
I'm not her what I think it was super
specific allegation the general idea is
that this was never really meant to be
successful for Trump and it was all for
publicity any thought he would have lost
by now you know I who really knows the
specifics of the Michael Moore
allegation I think it's interesting I
mean he's certainly acting in a way
where it almost seems like he's not
really interested in being the president
isn't he yeah yeah I know right and uh
it also seems like he's he's setting up
to like not be called a loser to or
whatever of course you know he's already
started lining up how it's all rigged so
basically if he wins he was able to win
despite it being rigged against him and
if he loses listen it was rigged against
them he couldn't do anything you know uh
yeah no absolutely yeah thanks so much
for the call I will uh yes I mean I tell
the I would tell the audience check out
Michael Moore's article and see if it's
uh compelling to you appreciate the call
hope to speak to you again warby parker
is offering a free five day home try-on
to give you the opportunity to check out
there
glasses i personally wear warby parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at warby parker trial dot-com / TDPS i
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker calm /
TDPS it costs nothing